-Welcome, welcome. Thank you
for coming on the show.
I know you know
I'm a giant fan of yours.
-Can I first say one thing?
-Yeah.
-Dreams come true.
I mean, the last time
I was in this studio,
I was back there.
And to sit here is insane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm happy --
-Well, I mean,
I'm not expecting you
to remember this,
but I got a D.M.,
as one does on Instagram,
and it said, "Oh, hey, Matt.
I'm a fan.
Keep up the good work -- J."
And it was from
some troll account, I thought,
of course, right?
-Yeah.
-And I called my daughter in,
Clara, and I was like,
"Clara, do you think
Jimmy Fallon really sent this?"
And she's like,
"Dad, that is for real!
That is so for real!"
And I was like, "No way!"
And then, like, here we are.
It's crazy.
Thank you.
-No, I'm a big fan of yours.
Yeah, so I had to slide
into your DMs.
-That didn't sound good.
[ Laughter ]
-...and tell you -- tell you
what a great job you're --
Here's -- I found --
I don't know how I found
this -- this magazine,
but I also subscribe to --
You have a Substack thing.
-Yeah.
-But I have --
I love this
because it's everything.
It's food, it's cars,
it's cool watches.
It's stuff that, like --
like -- like, this guy...
makes Saa-- he collects Saabs
or cleans up Saabs.
-You could buy that car now.
I think it's on Bring a Trailer.
I mean, the magazine started
because I selfishly
wanted to create
something for myself.
-Really?
-Because I was in the --
I kind of grew up
in the magazine business.
I was a photographer,
and then I was working
in Legacy Publishing,
but I was always
buying 6 to 8 titles
to kind of, you know,
feed my magazine lust.
-Yeah. Like, so you get
a food magazine,
you get a "GQ,"
you get a "Bon Appetit."
You get -- yeah.
-All of that.
All those magazines
in one magazine.
Did you have a hard time
paying for this?
Like, how...
-Well, I always wanted
to do this magazine,
and, basically, my wife and I
got fired from --
from Legacy Publishing.
And I was like, "Oh, my God,
congratulations.
Like, this is the best thing
that's ever happened.
Now we could kind of do
exactly what we wanted."
-I love this attitude.
-So, my wife
is a creative director,
has been a creative director.
And I was like,
I knew we kind of
could build a magazine.
-Yeah.
-But I didn't know how
I was gonna pay for it.
I didn't know how we were
going to distribute it.
And one night --
I live in Brooklyn --
a London planes tree,
which are those big trees
that you see along the streets
of neighborhoods
like mine in Park Slope,
broke off, fell, and landed
on the only car on the block,
which was my car.
So it landed -- it landed down
the middle of this Land Rover.
It completely
squashed the car.
No other car was hit.
And then, the next day,
I was sitting at my stoop
with the insurance adjuster,
sitting on the stoop
with the insurance adjuster.
The city came by
with a truck and a crane,
and the insurance adjuster --
You know, they want you
to keep the car, always, right?
And he's like, "Oh, okay, yeah.
I think we're gonna be able
to salvage this car, Matt."
And the city came by
with one of those crane trucks,
and it picked it up,
picked up the tree,
and it slipped, and the tree
fell again onto the car.
It was like Bugs Bunny.
[ Laughter ]
-He goes, "Now we can't
fix the car, Matt."
-And he looked --
he put -- he closed his,
like, 1985 Dell computer.
[ Laughter ]
And he was like, "We're gonna
cut you a check for the car."
And I came in --
He cut me a check right there.
I came into the house,
and I said,
"We are gonna pay
for this magazine
with that check
from the fallen car."
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that's how it all started.
-That's how it happened.
And now you have that.
And then, led to your books.
"A Man & His Kitchen."
I have the other books --
"A Man & His Watch,"
"A Man & His Car."
-That's right.
-"A Man & His Kitchen."
All this stuff is like --
it's your taste.
It's all in your brain,
the stuff you like to cook.
There's the stuff
you like to do.
I know that you lived in
an Airstream for like a year,
I want to say,
and you grilled on a Weber grill
for a whole year, every dinner.
-That was at William Brown Farm,
and that was his farm that we --
It's a piece of land
we bought in Upstate New York
almost 20 years ago,
and we found this piece of land.
There was a mobile home on it
and a barn, like one of those
Fisher-Price red barns.
And we got rid of
the mobile home --
key word being "mobile."
And we lived in
an Airstream, seasonally,
until, like, the hose froze.
And that --
And then we built this house
and all these kind of
great lifestyle experiments
that happened
at William Brown Farm.
And this book is a collection
of those recipes,
how we entertained,
and how we share meals
with family and friends,
and, you know, food souvenirs
that I bring back
from traveling,
things I love
from Upstate New York,
like hot dogs and chicken wings.
-Yeah.
The thing I love
about you is, like,
there's -- there's
something in there.
There's like a beautiful old
watch that you've got to go,
"Oh, my God, it's a
gorgeous-looking watch,"
or a great suit.
And then you're like,
"And here's how
to boil hot dogs in beer."
And you go -- yeah.
That makes it fun.
-Yeah. That's one of
my favorite recipes in the book.
-Were you always into cooking?
-You know, I was -- I grew up
in a big Italian family
in Upstate New York,
in Binghamton. Shout-out.
-Yeah, Binghamton. Absolutely.
I know Binghamton very well.
-And my aunt had a diner,
Laura's Luncheonette.
My uncle had a bar aptly named
Uncle Tony's that served food.
So I kind of grew up
around these kind of amazing,
mostly women who were
cooking and nurturing
and, you know --
and I was hiding out, like,
you know, trying not to get
abused by an uncle,
you know -- not physically.
-Thank you.
-I think -- hoo!
-Verbal abuse.
And I, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-You can read all about it
in "A Man & His Therapist."
It's a great one.
-Tell me about your uncle.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And so I grew up around
all that -- all that stuff.
And when I was up at the farm,
I started keeping a journal
about all these experiences.
But, like, my early influences
with food
was these diners
and these restaurants.
And I loved cooking shows
on television.
Like, television
was my educator.
-What was your favorite show?
-I loved Jacques Pépin.
I loved The Galloping Gourmet.
-Love Jacques Pépin.
-Yeah, I think you made
an omelet one time with Jacques.
-Yeah. Oh, my God,
I'll never forget it.
-And I loved
cooking shows so much,
and I was living
in such a deep fantasy life
in Upstate New York,
I used to pretend
I had a cooking show.
And my mom had a beauty shop
in the house, as one does.
And I remember,
I'd be in the kitchen,
which was above the beauty shop,
and there was
this picture window
looking out to the backyard,
and I would be making
a bologna sandwich.
So I'd say like, "So you take
two pieces of bologna,
you put mayonnaise
on one side, a little --
You crush the potato chip
into the --"
And my mom would yell up
from the basement.
She would say, "Matthew,
who are you talking to?"
[ Laughter ]
And I would just say, "Mom,
I'm talking to
my television audience."
And she would just say,
like, "Okay."
Like, she never --
[ Laughter ]
-See?
But look who you became?
-She never, like --
I don't think she --
I think she still thinks
I have that show.
-Yeah. Congratulations.
Yeah.
I love this pose that you do.
You post these on Instagram.
You're just always posing
with a drink,
a nice cocktail, and some,
like, raw meat or something.
-Well, that's called
the meat pic.
-Yeah.
-Be careful if you google that.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
You want to be really...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't google that.
Yeah, yeah, no, don't google it.
No, don't -- We'll think of
a different name for it, yeah.
-But if you hashtag #MeatPic
on Instagram,
it's a pretty --
it's a straight dive into these.
[ Laughter ]
-...into these pictures.
-We hope.
-We hope, yeah.
We just hope.
I was thinking,
if you don't mind,
I'd like for maybe
you to teach me
how to maybe
do the pose tonight with some.
-Well, you need a tray of meat,
which is really helpful.
-How did this come about?
-So, we used to visit these
friends who had --
I don't know --
10 kids, 8 kids.
And we would always be like
10 or 12 people for dinner.
And there would always
be so much food.
And I remember, one time,
there was this cookie sheet
just, like, filled
with sausages and stuff,
and I was like,
"That is so absurd.
Take a picture with me
with this thing,"
and I had my picture taken.
And then every time
there was a big pile of meat,
we just kept doing it,
and then we kept posting it.
And then my wife
doesn't leave me alone.
Like, if we're cooking,
she's like,
"That is definitely a meat pic."
And so we just started doing it.
[ Laughter ]
And thank God.
-I love your wife.
-Thank God for the Internet.
The --
You know, people send me
their versions of the meat pic
from all shapes and sizes.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Yeah. Again, I'm so sorry.
-Yeah.
Censored.
-But, you know, I've had
meat pics from vegetarians...
[ Laughter ]
...pescatarians...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-...my uncle.
-Yeah. Oh, sure.
Your uncle.
Yeah, of course.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-I've always wanted a rimshot.
-You got to do it.
Come on. You got a rimshot
on "The Tonight Show."
I thought we could do a pic.
-You want to give it a try?
-Yes. What do you have?
A beautiful cocktail right here.
-So, my -- one of my
favorite drinks are the --
My favorite drink
is the Negroni.
I wrote a book about Negronis.
I have more pictures of Negronis
than my -- sorry, Clara --
than my daughter.
[ Laughter ]
But I'd like to do it...
-Yeah, I saw Clara
is in the book, by the way.
A couple of recipes for Clara,
the banana bread.
Shout-out to Clara.
-Yeah, she runs a diner.
-Yeah. All right.
Why don't we do this?
Let's do this right here.
-Okay.
-How do I...
-I'm right-handed,
so I hold the drink.
-All right. You hold the drink
in the right hand.
-Right. And then, you know,
people do this wrong
all the time.
Like, they'll hold it low
or they'll get lazy
with the drinking.
It's got to go high.
[ Laughter ]
So you got to get it
above the shoulder.
Right? And then you tip it
toward camera.
And let's say cheers.
Cheers.
-Cheers.
You sip your drink.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mmm!
-Mmm!
Matt Hranek!
"A Man & His Kitchen"
is out now.
It makes a great gift.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Depeche Mode.
Stick around, everybody!